[Music]
what's up marble ice agent M here at San
Diego comic-con 2019 now I literally
just got out a whole age the massive
epic world shattering cosmos shattering
multiverse shattering Marvel Studios
panel there's so much to talk about
let's dive into the highlights from the
panel all right start tough we get a
little bit of a look back at where we
came from first three phases and we're
calling the infinity saga which is
incredible crowds going crazy going wild
Kevin Feige is out there he is the
master and then we dive into phase four
the Eternals that's how we start things
off it's a new team of superheroes in
the MCU and Kevin Feige introduced
director Chloe Zhou followed by stars
from the film including Richard Madden
as a chorus Kumail Nanjiani as Kingo
borin rid off as Macari Brian Tyree
Henry as Fastow's Salma Hayek as a Jack
Lea McHugh is sprite Don Lee as
Gilgamesh and Angelina Jolie as Lena and
that will come to you November 6 2020
that's the Eternals I can't wait of
course we're talking about movies we're
also talking about Disney Plus Falcon in
the Winter Soldier is gonna be an
original Disney Plus series it's gonna
be great action filled adventures as
they fight together against the evil
after the events of Avengers endgame and
you have Anthony Mackie and Sebastian
Stan coming back to reprise their roles
as the Falcon in Winter Soldier
they came on they greeted the fans but
it was also revealed that Daniel Bruhl
will return as the villain Baron Zemo he
came out he put on the mask in this
video I lost it I lost it then we have
to have another new movie to talk about
Marvel Studios shang-chi and The Legend
of the ten rings this one is so cool we
announced and confirmed the casting of
see movie in the title role of shang-chi
director is destined Daniel [ __ ]
they came on they greeted the audience
was amazing all right we got to talk
about Wan Division Marvel Studios Wan
division coming to Disney Plus it's an
original series where Paul Bettany
reprises his role of
and Elizabeth Olsen returns as Wanda
Maximoff Scarlet Witch and they were
joined on stage by newcomer Tiana Paris
Mikey announced that Paris will be
playing the grown-up version of Monica
Rambeau you guys
it was just like fireworks going off
across the hall one division will
premiere on Disney Plus spring 2021 all
right we got a lot more to talk about
Loki are you ready for Loki you're not
ready for Loki I'm telling you Kevin
offered news on Loki which is a Marvel
Studios original series streaming on
Disney Plus in the spring of 2021 Tom
Hiddleston he's coming back as Loki
people were losing their minds there was
a Loki chant I may have joined in what
are you gonna do what about in the
theaters how about Marvel Studios Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness you
know that title straight hot fire this
movie will be directed by Scott
Derrickson
star Benedict Cumberbatch we also found
out that Elizabeth Olsen will also star
in Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness they talked about how Wanda
vision will also tie into this Marvel
Studios film Marvel Studios Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
hits theaters May 7th 2021 okay next up
was mm I don't know if the thing that
like made my heart explode a million
times over which is Marvel Studios what
if and that is a brand new all new
animated series in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it is being created exclusively
for Disney plus feature stories that
present alternate realities in the
Marvel Universe many actors from across
the MCU will reprise their roles as
voice talent in the series okay so we
got so much more to talk about Hawkeye
you guys like Hawkeye how about Marvel
Studios Hawkeye Jeremy Renner coming on
stage to reveal the previously
undisclosed title of the Disney Plus
original series he joined Kevin to give
exciting news about Hawkeye including
details about Keith Bishop character
well-known in Marvel Comics she'll be
integral in that series and that made me
screamed like legit scream Marvel
Studios Hawkeye launches on Disney Plus
in the fall of 2021 you're like okay
that's that's it right like that is like
no no no Marvel Studios gives you
or love and thunder it was revealed that
Jane Foster played by Natalie Portman
will become the Mighty Thor the goddess
of thunder like I've done I did I am
dead and I have risen back to light the
director Tycho yct Chris Hemsworth Tessa
Thompson Natalie Portman they were all
on stage for the presentation that will
come out November 5th 2021 all right
you're like okay but what about the next
film from Marvel Studios well we got to
see a whole bunch of really cool stuff
for Marvel Studios Black Widow and that
is the first film from face bore that'll
be the first thing to hit the big screen
Scarlett Johansson was there reprising
her role of Natasha Romanoff as well as
newcomers to the MCU David Harbor as
Alexi aka the red Guardian I just shot
off in a space and came back Florence
pew as Jelena ot tag Pinelli as Mason
and Rachel Vice as Molina following the
Black Widow presentation Kevin Feige had
another big surprise up his sleeve for
the crowd he was joined on stage by
actor Maher Saleh Ali and announced new
Marvel Studios feature film played oh my
god you guys this was incredible so much
more to talk about really soon
[Music]